dès le début nous avons nous sommes
confrontés une question religieuse
puisque c'était un mouvement
nationaliste qui est disons le sionisme
enfin dans ses différentes composantes
qui a d'ailleurs éliminé de ses
composantes
ceux qui en son sein qui estimaient donc
que le sionisme une certaine légitimité
historique morale culturelle qui a
éliminé des gens comme herta müller dont
il était question tout à l'heure parce
que martin guilbert comme d'autres comme
yoda madness comme hannah arendt avait
conscience de l'existence d'une
population sur la terre que les
sionistes entendait s'approprier ou en
tout cas sur lequel ils entendaient se
veut développer qu'elle était partisan
d'une discussion et d'une installation
négocier préparer donc construite
politiquement et non pas une
installation par les armes mais je vais
sur le le point religieux je rappelle
tout de même que même si les pères
fondateurs d'israël je pense évidemment
à ben gourion n'était pas religieux même
si d'une certaine manière il avait un
certain mépris pour la religion le titre
de propriété qu'ils brandissaient pour
réclamer la propriété de l'occupation
cette terre c'était tout de même
l'ancien testament l'ancien testament
que je sache c'est un livre religieux
fondamentalement religieux et si ils ont
été soutenus par un certain nombre de
groupements religieux comme par exemple
aujourd'hui les nuls et les évangéliques
hellénique et bien c'est bien du fait de
ceux de réclamations de la terre promise
par part dieu donc on est d'emblée dans
quelque chose de le fait que un complice
d'une dimension religieuse n'est pas
nécessairement la halle annonce d'une
montée inéluctable aux extrêmes
[Musique]